welcome back everyone to stream in the
galaxy my name is rocket riley and today
we're going to be going over a frame by
frame breakdown of the second trailer
for spider-man no way home which dropped
some huge bombshells on the marvel
multiverse including the confirmation
that the sinister six will be in the
film setting the stage for one of the
craziest crossovers since avengers end
game but before we get started if you're
new to the channel please hit the
subscribe button and click the bell icon
to be notified when we upload a new
video now let's take a deeper look into
all the clues and easter eggs you may
have missed in the trailer
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
the trailer starts us off with an
injured peter parker sitting in the rain
and then the same shot we saw in the
first trailer of peter and mj swinging
across times square in front of the
banners from the daily bugle portraying
peter as spider-man with the tag public
enemy number one we again see peter and
mj standing on top of a large structure
surrounded by news helicopters peter
says he's only had one week since he was
bitten by the spider that his life felt
normal and that was when mj found out he
was spider-man which is probably true
since finding out you've gained the
abilities of a spider overnight is
probably quite overwhelming the two jump
down and into a tunnel barely missing a
subway as they fly by
we see a shot of peter entering the new
york sanctum still full of snow and ice
as well as the shots from the first
trailer where peter caused doctor
strange to botch the spell where
everyone would forget that peter was
spider-man
doctor strange is still wearing the eye
of agamotto even though thanos destroyed
it in avengers end game this has led
some to theorize that either this isn't
the doctor strange that we know or that
he repaired it to house a different
mystical artifact
doctor strange then says that since
peter botched the spell they've been
getting some visitors from every
universe which can only mean the
sinister six and potentially toby
mcguire and andrew garfield's spider-man
we then see the first shot of willem
dafoe's green goblin in the bridge fight
scene after he throws a pumpkin bomb
onto the bridge
this is one scene that we've seen quite
a lot of with many different angles and
shots shown of the different villains in
this particular battle
we then see lightning blasting down
towards peter shot by the sinister six
member electro we see spider-man in his
black and gold suit during this
particular battle and then alfred
molina's doc ock ripping up through the
asphalt with his robotic arms in the
previously mentioned bridge battle
sequence
we again see doc ock say hello peter and
then some fight sequences between the
two that we have yet to see showing
peter jumping over one of the robotic
arms and then sliding under a concrete
tube being swung at him
we then see peter being held upside down
by doc ock below the bridge and he
transitions his armor to cover his chest
instead of his face as doc ock slams
peter into a concrete pillar
in this shot he seems to be missing some
of his suit powered by nanotech similar
to how tony lost some of his iron man
suit in the fight with thanos on titan
peter's suit is likely missing pieces
due to the battle and at this point he
has to shift his armor to the places
where it's needed the most to keep him
protected you can even see his tie
hanging down from his body before it's
covered by the nanotech as doc ock slams
him into the pillar
doc ock then says you're not peter
parker which shows us that the doctor
must know something strange is going on
he was expecting to see toby mcguire's
spider-man under the mask but instead
got tom holland leaving him with a
puzzled and somewhat disappointed look
on his face he then hurls a car at peter
and he does a backflip over it similar
to how rey flipped over kylo ren's ship
in star wars the rise of skywalker
we then see ned mj and peter questioning
doc ock in what looks like the basement
of the new york sanctum based upon the
lighting and aged decorations dock is in
a concrete prison cell-like structure in
the basement as well but you'll notice
that there's no door to the cell he's
likely held in the cell by some of dr
strange's spells since a concrete cell
wouldn't be able to hold doc ock anyways
the three friends ask him what his name
is and he says dr otto octavius to which
they laugh and ask what his real name is
we can also see that ned is holding a
crossbow he may have grabbed it to try
to help during the battle but a crossbow
like this is not likely to be much help
in a battle against the great dr otto
octavius
we then see a structure being built with
what looks like the statue of liberty
holding the iconic captain america
shield this construction site displays a
banner of the figure holding the shield
high and we can see the shield clearly
above the structure
next we see peter swinging above some
trees between power lines and as he
shoots out a web a gold bolt follows it
out this could be part of a tech
advancement made to assist in fighting
jamie foxx's electro or as part of an
enhancement made to the suit by doctor
strange to help fight any of the new
multiversal threats we then see peter
again in the black and gold suit
standing in front of electro who seems
to be powering up and as peter raises
his arm golden rings form around his
wrist quite similar to the ones we see
on doctor strange when he performs
spells
this is most certainly some sort of
upgrade made to the suit by doctor
strange to help fight or contain the
multiversal villains the suit also has
rune-like markings on it so it's
possible that the entire suit was made
by doctor strange strange then tells ned
mj and peter to scooby-doo this crap to
which mj replies that he should say
please and strange obliges
in the background we can see a mop
bucket which could be placed there in an
effort to try to clean up the sanctum if
this is the case then it probably won't
help because they're going to need a lot
more than a mop to clean that place up
mj's also seen wearing the broken black
dahlia necklace that peter gave to her
in spider-man far from home showing how
their relationship has continued up to
that point
we again see peter swinging through
power lines in his black and gold suit
followed by a lightning and sandstorm
destroying a building surrounded by news
vans including a van from the daily
bugle we see j jonah jameson in a
wide-angle shot of the destruction being
caused by electro and sandman
we again see doc in his cell but this
time we can clearly see that his robotic
arms are a different color than usual
now they're covered in red plating
rather than the normal silver plating
perhaps trading out some old technology
for some of peter and tony stark's tech
we see several more sequences from the
bridge battle scene including peter in
his iron spider suit and doc ock says
that he's fighting ghosts
doctor strange clarifies that these
villains all died in their own universes
fighting spider-man calling it their
fate to die at the hands of spider-man
next we see peter in what looks like the
spider-man ps4 costume but with gold
accents instead of white ones jumping
out toward one of green goblin's pumpkin
bombs just as it explodes followed by a
shot of all the destruction caused by
the villains at that same site
doctor strange then says he's sorry to
peter to which he replies i'm sorry too
and he slings a web towards strange
grabbing a box which is likely being
used to house the multiversal villains
we then see strange use a sling ring and
a magic whip to pull peter out of the
sky and push his astral form out of his
body as he's holding the mystical box we
then see another version of the train
battle between strange and peter as
peter says there has to be another way
talking about how strange says the
multiverse of villains have to die since
it's their fate
we get the iconic shot of doc grabbing
spider-man by the head with his robotic
arm and an up close look at his updated
stark tech looking plates on his robotic
arms
we again see jamie foxx's electro
fighting peter in a construction site
likely the same as the statue of liberty
captain america figure we saw earlier
but elektra looks much different from
his original appearance and the amazing
spider-man 2.
instead of having blue skin and blue
lightning now he looks much more like
the comic book version of the character
with yellow lightning shooting from his
hands and covering his face
he also seems to shoot a lightning blast
at d.gok causing him to fall off the
structure this could be because elektra
was not being cautious but i believe
it's because doc ock actually started
helping peter to find a way to keep the
sinister six alive i mean who wouldn't
want to see those two team up
next we see peter standing on top of the
statue of liberty's head and in the shot
he's still holding the box he took from
doctor strange we then finally get an
up-close look at the updated green
goblin costume as he hovers on his
glider and spider-man in his new suit we
see a figure that looks like a maskless
green goblin fly towards the camera but
it's hard to tell if this is potentially
someone else
peter and mj kiss and we see the
department of defense control surround
happy wielding guns pointed directly at
him
next we see golden rings explode out
from the statue under construction
similar to when peter botched doctor
strange's spell at the beginning of the
trailer
we see the lizard and electro squaring
off for battle against peter along with
a huge figure of sandman peter lands on
the statue of liberty's head and you can
see the giant shield in the background
the fight between the three villains and
peter begins and we notice that ned and
mj are on the statue as well as the
giant shield begins to fall tearing the
structure apart
mj also begins to fall and peter jumps
towards her very similar to the scene
when andrew garfield's spider-man tried
to save a falling gwen stacy but failed
i really hope that's not the case here
as they seem much closer now
lastly we see the statue of liberty
surrounded by what looks like cosmic
tears in the sky to other universes and
they look quite similar to images we've
seen in what if and loki both of which
gave us greater insight into the marvel
multiverse
doctor strange then says they're
starting to come through and i can't
stop them which could mean that either
more villains are coming or that toby
maguire and andrew garfield spider-man
are coming
either way it'll be so exciting to see
what strange meant by this
this trailer gave us a ton of
information to go off of but it didn't
include any depictions of eddie brock or
venom in an after credit scene and venom
let there be carnage the two were
transported to the mcu and saw tom
holland's peter parker on a television
this can only mean that venom 2 will
appear in the film
finally we didn't get any specific
confirmation that toby maguire or andrew
garfield will appear in the movie but
since the villains they fought in their
own movies appear and because doctor
strange says it's their fates to die at
the hands of spider-man it can kind of
be assumed that they'll make an
appearance
even if they don't i'll be so pleased to
see willem dafoe and tom hardy come
together in the mcu when the film is
released on december 17th
well that's going to be everything from
us today on marvel's newest trailer for
spider-man no way home if you enjoyed
the video please hit the like button and
don't forget to subscribe for more great
content what are your theories about the
new trailer will toby mcguire and andrew
garfield make appearances we'd like to
know what you think so drop your
thoughts in the comment section below
from everyone here at stream in the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching
you